[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
34th
live stream q a we are ready to go you
have filed
many a cue yes you have all right so
we will start by picking up wow i just
moved the entire operation
um i did not even know that was possible
um we're gonna start by reading a couple
of questions from
number 33 that we didn't get to and that
seemed particularly worthy of going back
to
question one is there truth to the loss
of one sense strengthening others
i am a near-sighted deaf person did i
get cheated or have i used my eyes too
much and worn them out
this is actually from our friend holly
there is definitely
truth in effect the mechanism may not be
what one imagines it would be but
let's say for example that you are not
using your
visual processing power for vision
because you're not getting inputs
that allows it to be used by other
senses and so and there are in fact some
extraordinary cases of this in um
people who are musical savants
who are typically blind so anyway we
should talk about that
at greater length another time but it's
very interesting
and uh for instance we know of people um
who can
actually who appear to be echolocating
right who are who are blind
and who echolocate and the echolocation
the the
actual processing of the sound in some
of these cases where it's been looked at
and i think it's never not true when
it's been looked at but
in some cases where it's been looked at
the sound processing is actually taking
place
in the normally optical processing part
of the brain oh i actually didn't know
that so
that matches um the hypothesis i have
advanced
for the savants was that they
effectively had a graphics card that
wasn't occupied with graphics
that could be utilized for the next
closest input which was
music
questions from last time is just a
comment that i thought warranted
mentioning here uh someone has sent us a
super chat uh donation for the cat
and the cat appreciates that very much
thank you which cat
uh probably the one who made a cameo
last time was fairfax
walked in front of yes he may show up
again
uh any advice on winning your liberal
friends back
all my friends were liberal um if you
lost them
because they couldn't stand reason i
would say
um upgrade better friends is what you
need well i mean that's
i just wonder if we can do a little bit
better and i don't i don't know
the answer but um
probably some of them could be reasoned
with that you know
friends may depart in a group and uh
some may be wondering
if there is there is anything to the
critique that this person presumably was
offering up so
i mean look if they come back and they
say whoa i blew it
that's one thing if they don't you
really want to invest your time
recovering people who were so blind that
even though they knew you
and they knew what you were made of that
they assumed that because
your perspective didn't match theirs
that uh
you were inherently wrong or bad i mean
some level who needs it um you know
come join the free thinkers
okay i'd like to come back here but
maybe not now okay um it turns out that
the first question
uh for this live stream is from the same
person as that question was which i
didn't notice until i just put them
right next to each other
and he's asking he i assume um
it's asking us because he gave a lot of
money um
to read a question that he put into
the comments somewhere was forwarded to
us by our moderator
um and i'm not going to read the whole
thing because this would take several
minutes um so i'm going to try to
summarize
um so this is basically an analogy he
yeah he is proposing an analogy to what
we proposed in the last
in 33 regard to the new the sort of
what he calls in the new neoliberal
movement which is not how i would
characterize it
as a ponzi scheme he says i was
considering a more viscous comparison
would be the degree to which modern
forecasting science
mirrors 20th century religious logic as
in why not believe in god because what
if you're wrong
or the scientists say it will get worse
so fall in line if you're wrong everyone
will suffer why are you trying to kill
grandma
he argues they are saying not only are
you wrong for questioning anything we
don't like but you're wrong as a person
worthy of degradation by virtue of who
you are and or what you represent
he says dr king was aware of how to use
uh good protesting um forces
and um
i can understand burning witches they
didn't know darwin or foucault but
what's grotesque about the current
standards is the fortitude behind we
don't
we know that you don't have control over
your demographic predicaments and we
know you didn't commit the sense of your
fourth
father's but we are going to burn you to
the ground regardless
um i'm not sure i gleaned how all that
fit together
i'm and i skipped some but i read the
whole thing before and i'm not totally
sure how it fits
so there's you know there's some
pascal's wager
stuff in there you want to spell that
out yeah um
that effectively uh you'd be a fool
to face your death as an atheist because
what do you get for being an atheist and
um throw your head in
right yeah um so anyway i don't
subscribe to it at that level though i
think the logic is sound
um i think there's something to be said
for
um the courage of your convictions
in in that case but um the
the real question is how do you separate
your
what is my
bayesian analysis of what is likely to
be true and then how do i translate that
into policy and how do i translate that
into policy
involves a cost-benefit calculation that
is not strictly speaking deducible from
what's true
so right um should you wear a mask if
there is
a five percent chance of it's being
useful
but downstream of you is likely to be uh
several people who will die if you don't
wear it then
yeah the point is you may think it's not
useful but the chances that you save
somebody's life are high enough and life
is valuable enough that you would adjust
the calculation
likewise in the case of uh climate
change for example
a lot of us um have become persuaded
that to confront climate change is
actually to create
um positive economic growth
that in fact we are retarding growth by
obligating ourselves
not to change the mechanism by which we
fuel things and that in fact
we've been sold a false bill of goods
that the thing that would happen if we
were to confront
climate change properly is austerity
rather than
prosperity and so in that case you
should do it because um modernizing what
we are
makes sense and it's rent seekers who
would prevent us from doing it oh man
can we just
this this is what needs to be shared
from the rooftops right
right right there rent seekers who don't
want us to address climate change
because they are the ones who are
winning with the current paradigm
and we can see more prosperity and
a more intact planet than the one we are
hurtling towards
uh if we address what's going on yeah um
there's a cartoon that i'm very fond of
i think
many of the um conservatives who are
doubtful of climate change or
anthropogenic climate change don't like
the cartoon but the cartoon is
um somebody says uh what if climate
change is a hoax and
we've made everything better for nothing
[Laughter]
all right um a federal judge
ordered oh a federal judge ordered
documents unsealed in the maxwell
epstein versus
gwifra defamation case to be released by
july 30th guffrey right fray i don't
remember goofy
um hundreds of other women have come
forward with lawsuits giving deposition
statements and contemporaneous evidence
the story needs your voice is there
incorrect modifier in there because it
sounds like the records are being
unsealed
that's got to be a good thing right yeah
unless i misunderstand no no i think i
think
i think he's saying hey this thing this
thing has happened happening would you
you know would you help
spread the word kind of thing i feel
like
there are so many stories that need to
be told and
certainly there are many that neither we
nor any of the people sort of in our
circle will end up
talking about because there are just too
many and especially because this is
something that eric has particular
knowledge about and um has voiced
uh his expertise on so many times i
i feel like he's he's he's done
he's done the due diligence on this yeah
but i'm not saying that you know we
won't
we won't talk about it but it's it's not
something that i'm focused on
it's it's what they were doing is
horrifying
well and the question though it's
implied here is
why right what is it why is the world
protecting
this and and so you know it potentially
is related to
the bigger the the what what goliath is
this yes
what what's what is the compromise doing
in this story
and how would the world be different if
it weren't there
and that's obviously a hugely important
question so
hopefully we will find out yeah
when do we get real news on unity 2020
the news has been soon for about a month
and you're beginning to sound like
blizzard entertainment with their soon
tm promises
i don't know what blizzard entertainment
is i don't need it i don't either but
it's got a trademark next to it
uh well is it a week a month not until
late september when do we hear more
that's why i'm just reading the question
yeah i know i'm just telling this
person so what we have is a
technological platform which is going to
be the first step
in a larger effort that is
literally less than 24 hours from being
unveiled if everything is
continues on the current trajectory so
you're about to get
a major change in the presentation of
unity 2020
and the ability for people to interact
with it so
i'm glad that you're excited i'm
interested in having this deployed and
i'm
i'm feeling as itchy as you are to see
it in the world
functioning so um hang on hang on just a
little bit longer and
you will you will see motion all right
brett you asked zubi for recommendations
for interesting rap i recommend
alyssa marie start with a dorno for
thoughtful and lyrical content that
reflects this
whole situation oh awesome okay
thank you love you both been tuned in
and with the idw learned much about my
own party trying to explain concerns
with family and friends
do you have a summary of concerns with
supporting evidence that i could use as
a primer to help them better understand
i don't know which party we're talking
about i don't but i i think it's gonna
be the democrats given um
given that given that we have you know
we have we have tended
to be more um pointed
and frequent in our criticism of what
who are supposed to be our own
uh feeling that we ought to clean our
own house first well you know making no
bones about um the fact that we're not
republicans and
never have been and and specifically
don't like trump
um but you know because we have
we have critiqued more often what the
democrats are doing i suspect that that
is the party in question here yeah um
it's actually a very difficult puzzle
because
um i think people correctly intuit
that if that structure is as compromised
as many of us
claim to know that it is then
they feel they have been left completely
adrift which they have
and so how do you convince somebody to
consider the possibility that the
structure that is the hedge against
chaos is in fact functioning in a
predatory fashion that is going to put
us
into chaos so i guess my point is
i don't think it's the evidence i don't
think the evidence is all that
complex i mean the fact is the democrats
marshall an absolutely appalling
candidate in 2016
despite the fact that there was a very
popular candidate
um on the rise they sabotaged sanders
why would they do that they would
sabotage sanders because sanders was
actually interested in change
now i don't think the change that
sanders was interested in
is the kind of change we should be
pursuing but nonetheless there was an
awful lot of energy
behind sanders and for good reason he
well and i mean so that was 2016.
they by my estimation they've promoted
what may be
somehow an even worse candidate in 2020
from a much deeper slate
from like there was i'm not
excusing anything that happened in 2016
but there was this heir apparent there
was this
you know we we actually we have
um powerful families in this country and
we're going to let the clintons continue
to
to reign sort of sort of thing and
that's not an excuse at all but it
explains a little bit
of what they might have been doing and
it's it's not even
it's not even as explicable um in this
case
to choose someone with um apparently
failing competencies
um when there was actually an incredibly
rich and diverse in terms of ideology
and experience
slate of canada's so i agree with you
and
that's where i was headed next is that
they've done this to us two elections in
a row
is amazing but here's the thing
people their their minds will not allow
them to make this switch but it looks to
me
like it's quite straightforward they
prefer
to lose to trump than to risk actual
change
this is because this is an influence
pedaling racket
an influence peddling racket cannot give
up its
saleable good which is influence if it
decides to embrace a candidate
that actually would stand in the way of
corruption then it loses
its uh its profitability so by
putting feeble candidates up against
trump who it claims is the great evil
right if it really believed he was the
great evil and the answer is
who is most likely to beat him you think
andrew yang would lose to trump i don't
think andrew yang would lose to trump i
think he would walk all over
right the authenticity is there the
inside
the decency right i i've seen the polls
i'm still not writing off trump i don't
think biden's going to be oh and they're
they're shifting
actually as of as of this week well it
doesn't matter
at all and i must say in the few minutes
between our
initial hour and this i saw an extremely
disturbing
totally predictable clip in which um
biden walks on stage and um
says i'm so glad to be at somewhere that
he isn't
and then realizes he's made an error and
dismisses it as a joke which it wasn't
and it's like well if you can't get
through the first minute of your
you know i guess i am no fan of biden as
you know i'm
i'm more willing to excuse uh slips of
oh god what
if it's tuesday it must be birmingham
sort of sort of things but
you know once he actually has to start
engaging real things in real time like
real issues as opposed to do i remember
where i'm standing
oh i believe we're gonna see this all
over the place you know
any normal candidate could have made
such a slip
that's not what this appeared to be this
appeared to be a complete
lack of awareness and then a you know
kind of a go-to move to dismiss it
and the thing is it's so regular that we
see evidence
of his failing mental capacities does
anybody think
that you elect this guy and he makes it
four years in office
i think he steps down in one yeah so
who's the vp going to be
it's going to be kamala harris probably
um
and so the point is then we are signing
up for you know
a situation in which we've got a stuffed
shirt
running uh as a stalking horse for the
dnc's
chosen candidate who will not have been
elected in the same sense that the top
of the ticket person is elected
right this is this is dnc rule which i
find
utterly frightening even before you get
to the partnership they appear to be
striking
with the black lives matter with the
woke elements of the party
um so you know that's your party signing
you up for an absolute disaster and
potentially signing the country up for
civil war
so how much more evidence do you need of
the failure of the system
brett in q a number 16 in about 35
minutes oh i remember remember
i do get you there okay i'll just let
you answer the question then i will
continue
all right well i think i misspoke i i
think you probably did yeah
you suggested that pain was not a
prerequisite for consciousness
but might be a prerequisite for meaning
can you elaborate on the latter half of
that idea or give examples
thanks and love you both um
yeah what did i mean by that i think i
mean that
if you were to eliminate suffering as i
hear people
advocate there's no idea i like less
than this one
what you produce is a complete
flatness of experience either that or
you take
mild pleasure and it becomes the
equivalent of pain which may even be
what we are seeing in the streets in
other words
the lack of actual uh
overt racism in the system is now
causing
microaggressions to be boosted to the
level of violence right
isn't this what um you know very few
people actually
benefit from ssris from selective
serotonin reuptake inhibitors
used to treat very deep and dark
depression but
i believe and there is some clinical
evidence to support the idea that
the vast majority of people who are on
these things are simply experiencing a
flattening of affect
and that prevents them from actually
learning
how to control their own emotions
organize their own mood
and that flattening of affect is what
you just said
it's one of the ideas that you that you
hate most that you're scared of most
actually and we're seeing society-wide
right
and the fact is you probably know it
from your own life that
um you know the troughs give the the
peaks
meaning and so i think the thing is
meaning is really important
if you if you gave me the ability just
personally to be able to
erase um negative emotion
sensation there's no way i'd push that
button
no way that would be like death right
it's the equivalent it just removes
and you know the reverse calibration it
removes set point
and you know what what it does is it
moves all of your expectations just
up and now you've got a new frame but it
it's not going to make
there can be no utopia i mean it's the
same error right it is exactly the same
error we're seeking utopia we're seeking
into suffering
these things won't happen yeah and
another way to come at it is if you just
simply recognize that these things exist
in your mind
as a proxy to point you away from things
that hurt you and point you toward
things that are good
then do you really want to eliminate the
map program that allows you to navigate
because that's what it is
right it's a map program that steers you
towards goodness and away from badness
and
if you think about it that's the only
reason that you succeed in anything
yeah what do you think about calling for
a public debate between d'angelo and
kendy versus any two from the black
intellectual roundtable episode
for instance i'd love to see hashtag
coleman versus candy trending
i love this idea um deangelo and candy
wouldn't agree no they wouldn't agree
but it's not to say that we couldn't
find somebody on that side who would
which would be great
yeah um um yeah you know who might uh
what's his name
eric michael tyson did i make that up he
he
debated jordan peterson at one point oh
um
do i have michael eric tyson i'm just
making up yeah you're making up stuff
and i'm
not gonna be able to help you um
go off girl i love you guys i think this
probably came in when i was
ranting about masks uh
would you agree that conflating
anti-semitism with anti-zionism is a
dangerous game
in the uk criticism of netanyahu and his
far-right state is also being smothered
with the anti-semite club
oh yeah so i said uh probably two
episodes ago or so i said something
about
an anti-israel sentiment on black lives
matter website being
anti-semitic and i think i suspect that
that is what this is
in reference to yeah um i i have seen
and yeah yes it is that's a conflation
and it's not that that does not map
perfectly at
all um that said that
uh going after israel is often exactly
the dog whistle that we're told it is
and it is cover for anti-semitism yeah
there is a lot of that so
the problem is it's muddled but you know
there's obviously critique to be
delivered of israeli policy on the other
hand as eric points out
very clearly you have to do it in the
context of the problem you know as with
portland you have to do it in the
context of the problem that is being
addressed which is
a nation surrounded by uh hostile
neighbors
and so um anyway yes we would
i think all of us the decent folk would
desire a humane policy that allows
israel to get along with its neighbors
but
that the ability to have such a policy
is predicated on neighbors willing to
to play ball so anyway yes
there's dog whistle all over the place
and the distinction between
uh resistance to what's called zionism
versus anti-semitism is an important
dichotomy
apparently
michael eric dyson not tyson yeah dyson
yes oh zach says like the vacuum
um i am pessimistic that critical race
theory and postmodern
ideas can't be beat i think by which
this person means i'm worried that they
can't be beat because it appeals to the
human desire to be virtuous and moral
are you hopeful these ideas can be beat
if so what are some signs of hope
thanks for your hard work they can be
beat
but you have to you know it's about
context and the way they are winning
is not because the arguments are
difficult to beat but because
the um sustenance is
easy to deny to people so to the extent
that you can frighten people about
what's going to happen to them
and then offer them a hand they will
tend to take it and
so they're easily manipulated
if we are to successfully counter this
it requires
that we provide people someplace where
they have
um the security that they will not be
abandoned
and we should be working on that yeah
and and creating a counter narrative
which
can grab the claim of virtuous and moral
and i think that's going to be critical
and i don't know what that looks like
yet
well i mean the thing is so many people
i mean it's true
it's just true but i don't know what the
catchy soundbite
version of this actually resisting that
thing that's claiming to be virtuous and
moral
is in fact the virtuous and moral path
uh it's
it is i don't have the narrative on it
yet though
i mean it seems to me uh unfortunately
it's not as
catchy but yeah the answer is
do we continue with the project that we
were on and finish it
and make a fair society or do we unmake
that society because it was so
desperately unfair as it was
and that is it is actually isn't it and
um the classic framing of sort of
progressivism versus conservatism
involves a line without branches yeah
and
um there might be new branches there
might be forks to take
and some of those forks might actually
take require going back a little bit and
then taking a different
different road um but this thing this
critical race theory post-modernism
black lives matter the riots in the
streets um
really explicitly is about burn it down
uh and so you're not just you know i'm
of course imagining a cladogram an
evolutionary tree and it's like you just
you go back to base you just go all the
way back
and then we'll build something and we
don't know what it is
someone smarter than me we'll figure
that out right uh
and uh there's
that that that is not helpful at all yep
i am a public elementary teacher i'm
fighting for enlightenment values
reason and american and american
yet the post-modern culturally relative
anti-racists dominate the conversation
they want politics to be greater than
truth and emotion to be greater than
facts i don't think that's
quite what that's supposed to say um
they're all women he concludes help
um yeah there is
i am certain and i have not seen any
analysis of this because it doesn't
fit the accepted narrative um but i have
long had a hypothesis
based on a number of things that we
won't go into in depth here
um but there is most definitely a gender
by which in this case i mean
sex um element to this
that um women's greater tendency to
conform
just by like the psychological meaning
of conformity
and to be affiliative and also
to tend to have tools in their arsenal
that are less likely to be physical and
more likely to be linguistic and
emotional
means that women are more likely to be
the ones
who are leading the charge here
and uh just i never completed the
analysis i just did a simple
frankly just a simple chi square when i
first thought about this in light of
what was going on at evergreen i thought
huh i kind of feel like there are a lot
more women
you know when a at a college with a i
can't remember what it was but
you know something like a one-to-one sex
ratio um
among the faculty i feel like there are
a lot more women who are leading the
charge here and going after you and it
was true
um so and then i actually began to look
and did not complete the analysis
on trying to figure out what the
relative rates of
participation acquiescence and various
cults are
and it's it takes some doing to figure
out exactly which
lists to use and you know life got in
the way and i ended up doing a number of
other things but it looked at a sort of
a
you know this like i think this is right
um like indeed
uh women were more likely to be
participating in
these sort of mass movements that
require complete conformity from all
adherents
and that's uh if that's true that's
unfortunate but it's true and needs to
be something we can talk about i don't
know if
i didn't really address the question
except that he ends with they're all
women which
i think is a fundamental thing here
uh to end the pandemic sequence sars
covey ii antibodies
write them into a plasmid insert the
plasmid into a viral vector
then inject the vector or aerosolize it
is there any reason this won't work why
isn't this being done
um hold on i'll make sure i get the
whole plan here sequence the antibodies
get them into a plasmid insert the
plasmid into a different so
some black boxes here it's the insert
the plasmid in the viral vector is the
most obvious
so presumably the person is talking
about
growing the antibodies
in a bacterial culture
no oh i see maybe the idea is
this this person wants to gene therapy
your way to an immune response
like gene therapy out in the world yeah
i don't think it will work as a matter
of
scale of the immune response in the body
in other words how many
cells do you have to infect with a viral
vector that carries the antibody
sequence and
it is unclear to me if you can encode
an antibody into a
virus and get a cell chosen
let's say at random to make the antibody
you know i guess if it were this simple
this would be how
how vaccines were always made well i
think this person is asking
why wouldn't this work and so at some
level let's say you've got a b
cell which is the cell that makes
antibodies that b
cell has the machinery that takes the
sequence that is unique to the
antibodies
that are encoded by that b cell
and it produces antibodies which are
then exported to the surface of the cell
and spilled into the lymph for example
so that does not suggest that if you
breathed in a virus that contained the
sequence that makes
the antibodies and you got it into a
lung cell for example
that that lung cell would inherently
produce antibodies
in other words the machinery is what
causes the sequence to produce
antibodies so
if it were true that you could dump a
sequence into
any cell and it would export antibodies
then potentially there's something down
this road but if it's not true
you're not going to reach the cells that
have that machinery
so i i think there's it's a very
interesting idea yeah
um but i don't think it works as
described
great i mean unfortunate but lovely it's
not great yeah
how can i help my left-leaning friends
see the danger in left-wing
authoritarianism they're not extremists
just normal reasonable folks caught up
in the rhetoric
i love all the sanity from the live
streams parenthesis not sarcasm
yeah how do you get it to see it i mean
i feel like god we
we keep getting some version of this
question and i keep on really wanting us
to
figure out how to answer it i don't
think we figured it out i think the
thing is if it were figurable
in that sense then it'd be figured yeah
i mean at one level
it's obvious that there can't be a
single answer you know it's it's going
to be context specific
whatever the answer is so it's going to
be particular to
your friends you know but also you know
we
you're writing that so you're here
listening to us uh it's not like we
succeeded at this when this when this
first happened in our world
right there there were several people
in our community many of whom we called
friends uh
who uh flipped on us
none of our students did right but many
of our colleagues our so-called
colleagues
on the faculty and the staff so
we clearly don't there is no
even we didn't have a complete answer
although although i will say however
that
the fact that our our students didn't
flip on us and it was the students our
students with whom we had a closer
relationship you know we we had
we had we had led every program with
care and compassion
and and and in an anti-authoritarian way
telling them do not do not trust me do
not trust us simply because i'm the one
up here with a degree and
going to be writing your narrative
evaluation at the end whereas
the relationships that we have with
adults in our lives uh don't tend to
tolerate that kind of thing
right they they don't tend to allow for
that much
um playing around with what actually are
the boundaries of
what you're supposed to push and what
you're not and it's rare that a friend
can tell another friend come on i want
you to push me around please push me
around i'll push you in response
um so you know maybe looking forward
establishing as you're coming to know
people that that's sort of an
expectation
i mean it's something i don't think
you've ever been explicit about this but
it's something that you
do you just you push people around
whether or not they want to be pushed
either they stick around like oh i don't
know what that was but it kind of made
me feel good and
not good but now i know more and it's
better um
so for for most for for most people who
aren't you
brett um maybe even being explicit
uh with people in advance like i
i hope you push my boundaries and i
i'll try to push yours too and that's
going to make us
a more anti-fragile relationship yeah i
think there's also something
to the selection process where you know
you kind of want to discover that people
um
don't lose their minds when somebody
tries to manipulate them
and what's really happening is that this
ideology is
manipulating people and most of them do
not have the tools to resist it so
in some sense the friendship process
tends to default too much to
do we believe the same things do we
have the same interests when in fact
it's in many ways much more important
that somebody uh share your values even
if they see the world differently
and frankly those are the more
interesting friends to have in any case
because
those friends often know something you
don't but they're trustworthy and so
you do have more disagreements but
they're also
useful disagreements yeah
should i inoculate my co-workers to
white fragility by introducing it to
them early and mocking it with them
before the diversity trainers come
if everyone has already laughed at it
together social pressure might not work
yes brilliant ideas this is exactly what
you should do
and i'm sorry that you will end up
having to read it um but
this this this is how we beat this crazy
regressive racist ideology that's
exactly how you do it and can i suggest
uh over-the-top british accent sort of
monty python style you read it to each
other that could work very well
absolutely
yeah flying the flag upside down has
historically used been used as a
distress signal
signal not as a tool of showing
disrespect it hasn't been until recently
that displaying it that way uh became a
form of protest
interesting i didn't know that that is
interesting uh
my college my college the colorado
school of mines is interested in working
with you i have been tasked with
reaching out
uh check your patreon if you want more
info depending on what that means
i mean we're not miners cool i'm trying
to remember
who it is oh i know who it is yeah we
know someone there yeah it's
uh derek jensen he's not there
no he's not there but he studied there
oh that's right yeah
um anyway so that's interesting he's in
far far far northern california but he
studied there you're right yep
yeah um yeah well
i guess probably you mean brett's
patreon which means it's going to be a
lot of
going through but um yeah okay
uh where was i
would love to see a long conversation
between heather and lionel shriver over
the current state of fiction and the
need for narratives
how do i have to talk to make this
happen oh i would i would love that
she's fabulous i actually recently at
our friend holly's suggestion
read kevin book what's it called
um we have to talk about kevin something
like that everyone will know it is kevin
terrifying amazing brilliant book and it
just deepened my
respect for her and she is one of
very few contemporary
excellent and successful authors who's
just
putting up with this [ __ ] in no way yeah
is this even free speech how can
trotting out pernicious nonsense and
inciting riots where people are being
killed
not equivalent to yelling fire in a
crowded theater uh what are the
implications if you agree with us
um i think i understand the question in
which case it's like
shouting fire in a crowded republic uh
which i agree it is yeah we're putting
everything in jeopardy setting fire in a
crowded republican
setting fire to the crowded republic
putting everything in jeopardy
uh on the basis of a set of positions
that are
so dumb that i really believe
essentially no one
is simple-minded enough to actually
believe them in a literal sense
and the whole thing is predicated on
the pretense that the street is
demanding it which it isn't the street
is
confused so yeah i would say it is
equivalent or
worse 37 minutes okay
uh let's read two more here and then
we'll go to the other
um super chat brett and heather what
indicators are you looking for that we
have reached the point of no return
regarding social and political divisions
when is it time to head for the hills
um it's funny uh
that's the second time in two days i've
heard that phrase and i
think i have said it recently i don't
know if it's catching on or what
head for the hills and for the hills um
yeah i mean i don't know about the point
of no return because i don't know quite
what the point of no return is
from i think we have found ourselves
in very dangerous waters
it can get worse from here easily and
will if we do nothing
um you know increasingly
eric has a phrase for this is it the
don't bother to
pick up your dry cleaning moment and i
actually think
that moment doesn't that moment is not
the one
we are looking for that that moment
comes so late in a process
that it is misleading the fact that you
haven't reached that moment yet
um shouldn't be nearly as comforting as
it ends up being
so so do you have a replacement
suggestion
i mean the question is you know is this
podcast a
from the hills podcast i think it might
be
right if we headed for the hills i think
we did so
what do you expand on that a little bit
what do you mean well you know
you may not remember this but at one
point we were tenured professors and
we had a day job and all of that
remember that um
and so anyway that was a plan we could
have attempted to
stick with that plan which would have
required us to compromise ourselves in a
way that we wouldn't
so we didn't and that meant
that we left some structure in favor of
some
unknown that strikes me as the hills
from which we are now
striking back at the thing that uh put
us in jeopardy and it's now putting the
republic in jeopardy so
yeah i guess i don't know what the hills
looks like anymore well and you know
we're not
um we're not equipped as survivalists
um but we know better than most people
who aren't explicitly in that camp
actually what it would take uh to to
live to actually be autonomous unlike
the
the yahoos who claim to be setting up
autonomous zones and are
relying on city water and lights and
cell service and all of this right
like we actually do have a sense having
lived remotely
um in places like madagascar and um and
just having
really you know taught a number of these
these things as well
um what would it mean
for people to really start trying to
disassociate
from the services
that we are all currently relying on
such that if they fail
you don't immediately go down the fact
is
that almost no one can really grow
enough food and source enough water
for themselves and their loved ones that
depends depends where you are
it depends where you are but unless you
already have that setup
right and some people do but um you know
heading for the hills
from you know from the house in the city
i'm not sure if this question is really
about
literal headaches you know it's both
though i think it's metaphorical and
it's literal
yeah i don't know how to answer it
um yes we are at some moment where some
level of heading for the hills
is warranted and has already happened
and
then there's obviously a moment at which
literally you flee your home
and you know there's not really food
enough in the hills
right for very many people so
are either of you familiar with dr bruce
lipton's discovery regarding stem cells
and epigenetics
i find it to be very similar to your
breath lab mice telomeres discovery
i don't know him it's ringing a bell but
i can't quite dredge it up i i agree i
feel the same way
all right let's go to the next zach's
there line there is a line look at that
walk into a room with a hundred people
racially proportional to the u.s
who do you most want to talk to if you
considered values and ability first are
you still racist
um i i get maybe this is
i don't think i don't think i get the
question
i think i get maybe what the question is
trying to ask but i don't believe the
premise of the question yeah i don't
believe the premise of the question
either and you know it's definitely not
my instinct
i want to talk to the person who is
least like me
who is most ready to um
be candid that's often the most
interesting conversation in the room
that's that's one of the main reasons
that travel is so exciting for both of
us right that you actually get to engage
with people who have so little in common
with you
in terms of your uh developmental and uh
geographic and political
uh history that you just really learn
something about what being a human is
about what the what the commonality is
and the commonalities
shine through um but you but you learn
tremendously and you know so sure you
know if you walk into a room
interested in you know where your goal
is i need to learn about
virology and there's two virologists and
98 non-virologists you should probably
talk to virologists first although it
might turn out that they're yahoos
um and um and i don't i guess i don't
if it weren't 20 20 i would literally
have no idea what racist was doing in
this in this question
you know and i i i it just doesn't it
doesn't belong there i think the
question is
asking if a prejudice
is accurate are you
so it's not racist it's prejudice are
you prejudiced are you a bigot
you know are you a values bigot i think
the problem is
you know a prejudice doesn't tell you
very much a prejudice can be accurate
like a prejudice you know if
if you describe somebody as a woman
then i have a prejudice about the likely
uh you know her height yeah right it's
based on
an actual experience of women being
shorter on average
so that's not a pernicious prejudice
right
but i mean let's a little bit more
complicated um
everyone i would pause it um and there
will be a few exceptions i'm sure
um it has a prejudice for attractive
people
because attractive is the prejudice that
selection has built in that is an
indicator
that's what attractiveness is it's what
it is right like it is it is
actually what it is so that's not
that's that's a tautology and yet it
sounds like a grievous insult
to those who aren't attractive but but
no
it's just you know why is it that we
find attractive what we do and
we can talk about how uh how
how cultural norms about what the most
attractive body type for instance have
changed over time
but the fact is that things like
symmetry
and and particular kinds of facial
structures
are i think universally across cultures
considered more attractive than others
and you know put aside all the things
about
makeup and costuming and tattooing and
you know other things that people in
different cultures do to themselves to
make them more attractive and that is
highly culturally specific but
attractiveness
um across the board is selection's way
of informing you of
um yeah that's that's someone who's
healthy on average
yeah if moms are more related to so
okay i'm gonna pause this is gonna be
this is an echo question so it's gonna
be
interesting but i have to have to give
give it some thought if moms are more
related to sons
and dads to daughters so this is picking
up on her question from a while ago
um
i'm just going to read it first if moms
are more related to sons and dads to
daughters
given that y codes for not very much
are systems favoring male line
descendants like aristocracy
really in favor of the matriarchal line
in terms of genes
um i think i follow yeah yeah yeah uh so
let's just
because this is in reference to a
question we answered a couple of
or last q a um the idea being that the y
is a very small chromosome
and um
dads are going to be more highly more
related to their daughters than they are
to
sons because they have given an x
chromosome to daughters
and only a y chromosome to sons and so
they share just
there's just more genome there that
they've given to daughters meaningful
genus more meaningful genome but i'm not
are moms do we establishes our moms were
related to sons
yeah i'm having trouble seeing that i
don't yeah i don't i don't see that
because moms are just
moms because they only have the x to
give um
no the idea is that it's a smaller
genome overall
and uh the dad gave the smaller bit and
yeah
so the mom has contributed a greater
fractional percentage of the
total genome to sons okay so we've kind
of done the basic
genetic relatedness part of this
question um
is it possible if that's true that
systems favoring male line descendants
like aristocracy are really in favor of
the matriarchal line
in terms of genes so i think the
question is asking
can it be a driving force yeah
my guess is it would be a very very weak
driving force
um but i agree although it you know what
it raises for me
is what all is coated on the x and
you know we there's a lot of work on
what's coated on the y
uh in part because it's understood that
it sets so much important stuff in
motion
in a way that the x doesn't you know the
x doesn't have
sex specific um instructions because
both males and females have an x and
females just have two
in mammals so i i would be interested to
know what is on the x
such that um you know moms can drive
yeah can can can drive the male line
um by virtue of contributing x on the
other hand it's one of her what's one of
two
and so you know you may have basically
competition between the two x's
yep so there's also a question
of uh
is it bar bodies
the leftover inactivated uh well
is it i'm trying to remember which one
of these factors it is in
somatic cells females typically have one
of their x chromosomes
inactivated to to compensate for
dosage i think that one's bar bodies
although i don't remember for sure
can't recall but in any case what i
would say is the
much more dominant factor here rather
than the slight difference
in relatedness is the certainty of
paternity versus certainty of maternity
issue so the fact is many fathers aren't
actually fathers at the genetic level
that is a much more powerful force than
the little difference in
how much sequence identity there is
between fathers and
mothers and sons and daughters so anyway
that's certain to be true
yeah and that you're right that's that's
highly explanatory
okay so this again would load if you
address my previous email
this this is about the the question
that i tried to read from email that we
were having a hard time parsing
thoughts on a third strand dna model
many books are out on the topic and it's
possibility some claim that this
covet vaccine will add the third strand
covertly
i don't know what this means no i don't
know i don't know what a third strand
dna model would
i don't know the only thing i know about
is um yeah this is certainly not what
the question's about but it's the one
relevant piece of information i have
telomeres it turns out are not just
linear sequences that stick off the end
of a chromosome
they form something called a d loop in
which
there's a free so you've got
double-stranded dna that's
looped over and one strand goes farther
than the other and the part that sticks
out which would ordinarily trigger the
dna repair machinery is actually
inserted
in between the double strands at a
particular place so you have this
loop that is telomeres grow shorter with
replication gets smaller and smaller at
some point it's critically short and the
cell doesn't divide anymore
but it creates this little tiny section
of triple stranded
dna where that little free end is
inserted between the two other strands
oh interesting so that's the only triple
stranded dna i don't know anything about
yeah all right sorry best i can do
um someone asking again for updates on
unity 2020
is it too late right in what's happening
uh
stay tuned hopefully 24 hours well
actually that will be an internal test
in 24 hours but not
not long thereafter you will have um
a lot of new stuff hello love your work
i'm hoping to visit and interview
portland protesters and rioters and
hopes of ascertaining ideologies and
aims
is that worthwhile also do you have any
coffee shop recommendations
um yeah uh
there was a lovely place called riot
ribs but apparently
it's not around anymore no i mean i
all the food recommendations in portland
are weird at the moment because
kovid but um i actually haven't been to
a single
coffee shop in portland that i didn't
enjoy so there's there
really any place you go is great um but
barbecued tacos is pretty good if you're
looking for food yeah that's not coffee
shop but uh yeah matt's barbecue tacos
on hawthorne is fabulous
just as as one of many um food directs
that plenty in the city
um
is it worthwhile to uh try
to interview portland protesters and
rioters what do you think
potentially nancy
i find people pretty pretty ready to
talk um and
i do think the discovery of the
variance in what they think they're
advocating
is certainly worth documenting um
that that is conspicuous and it is part
of this feat
uh this leaderless movement um and a
very frightening part because
there are lots of people there marching
for something that sounds reasonable
but they're marching along with people
who
are advocating for things that are
absolutely insane right
as someone considering going into
research science are there any
alternatives to playing the grant
writing game
like starting a company perhaps yeah
that's that's exactly the sort of
standard uh other thing to do
although uh you're probably then looking
for venture capital
um you know because it takes a while to
to you know r
d is very expensive long long time that
you need money before you end up with
product
if you're running a company um
yeah the grant writing game is the only
game in town in academia the one
exception was this little college in the
pacific northwest called evergreen
which as i understand it is rapidly
going out of business
um but it explicitly uh actually
all they need is for trump to suggest
that it is failing
which means that it will be succeeding
it will
yeah no they they should they should
work
you know what would they have to do to
get him to declare them a failure
because that would the donations would
through the roof
yeah oh my god don't don't help them
game this
um yeah so i scrolled way too far um
starting a company is there's a lot
a lot of ways that can look but yes
that's a that's a good alternative
do you think the social justice movement
has morphed into a social eugenicist
movement um
i'm not totally sure what that means i
can't um
i suspect it means something but i don't
well i mean look there are
hints of this nonsense yeah no actually
i do who you're required to find
attractive and
mate with and all this stuff the cotton
ceiling
um so anyway look i i wouldn't put it
past them i
don't think they're quite there yet but
no one actually um now that
it's had time to enter my brain and
percolate a little bit it was never
about justice
just like black lives matter seems to
have relatively little to do with black
lives mattering
and it was as we have said many times
many places
about turning the tables of oppression
rather than achieving actual equality of
opportunity as much as
possible and uh to turn the tables
and to uh turn and to turn the tables
in this way it appears to require that
you take some demographics and blame
them
and uh and yeah that's what's that's
what's being done
regarding losing liberal friends who
think you're too centrist peter bogosian
talks about disabusing
friends and colleagues and it starts
with empathy for their concerns
unyielding didacticism is a bad strategy
yeah i think actually in his and jim's
book uh
how to have impossible conversations he
talks about this um
he does and uh and that's that's right
that's a good that's a good approach so
there's a difference though
uh i took the original question to be
about what to do about
friends that you have lost and my sense
that's a very different puzzle than how
to address friends who
disagree with you and are looking at
your cross side
so that is not a hopeless predicament
absolutely um so anyway i did not mean
to dismiss i did not mean to say
cut your friends loose at the point that
they say something crazy
do you have a book recommendation on
evolving ecosystems i want to learn
about their efficiency for a personal
research project
thanks well ecosystems don't evolve
so that's going to be a problem with
regard to any
hypothesis that requires that they do
that's not to say that there aren't
people claiming that they do
but they don't yep something they change
over time
based on the evolution of creatures
within them
and somebody just pointed out on twitter
this um
this interesting process that happened
in yellowstone following the
reintroduction of wolves and actually
they wanted our input on it
where there was an entire cascade of
phenomena where the ecology
changed radically because this predator
began
not only eliminating deer including
elk and moose and things like that um
but
also causing those animals to behave
differently where those animals
had no predator they are suddenly wary
of certain places which means that the
things that they eat
are now returning to places that they
had been excluded so anyway a whole
cascade of effects that has
all sorts of yes uh downstream uh
in some cases literally creatures you
know right beavers
well that's i mean that's that's what
community ecology is supposed to be it
should be
it should be right um but but the
ecosystems themselves
aren't evolving units an ecosystem can't
reproduce itself
right so it's not evolving and this i
mean frankly i mean we've begun to hear
from some um honorable seeming and
awesome seeming ecologists who
um are listening and taking issue with
our occasional pointed barbs at
ecologists
um and it is in fact a long-standing you
know
this is one of our our beefs with our
field that um
too many ecologists seem to stop uh
what they're doing at the point that
evolution shows up and say well that's
not that's not my concern
obviously ecology and evolution should
be understood together should be learned
should be should be learned together
should be there they're
directly interrelated fields um but
there is i mean just as there are many
bad evolutionary biologists
um but there are whole sub-disciplines
in ecology that seem explicitly
anti-evolutionary
uh and uh the field of ecosystem ecology
seems particularly confused on this
front
uh and you know i i'm not gonna tell
these stories
i'm not gonna tell stories out of school
here now but um
i i have i have worked with people who
um
have been so confused on this point that
it rendered them incapable of
doing basic science and these are phd
scientists
yep i would agree um and you know
there's dysfunction on the evolutionary
side too
there's a blindness to ecology but
um it is less pronounced evolutionary
biologists at least
those who study adaptive processes are
well aware that ecology is important
yes they have little patience for it in
general and in
ecology space there's actually appears
to be a belief that you don't need to
understand the evolutionary stuff or
that it's so obvious
that um we all get it and we can just
move on right
i guess probably this won't be relevant
to this person asking but um
another bretner i used textbooks hardly
ever
um but there was one textbook that i
often made an optional text when i was
teaching
a population level like animal behavior
and vertebrate zoology and such
which is eric pianka's book that is
literally called evolutionary ecology
and it's it's excellent and it doesn't
it's not confused
about whether or not ecosystems evolve
or communities evolve
um but it's it is very much both an
evolutionary and an ecological
investigation
into what is true um of uh complex
living systems
yeah it's really in in my opinion it is
an attempt to form a field that
should have yeah taken over the
interface between
evolution and ecology and unfortunately
um it's still singular
it didn't it's this one pretty smart
small it's a you know it's a it's a
small
but fabulously expensive of course i'm
sure yeah um
at this point um textbook that is you
know it's also
not highly technical like even if you're
not super mathy you know he
obviously there's some math there but
you can you don't have to
delve deep in into the calculus to
understand almost anything in the book
and
it's terrific and you're right it's
singular yep he contacted me after the
evergreen
uh what ut austin i think something like
that forgotten where he is but yeah
anyway he had a lovely interaction
blizzard guy yep
he likes lizards human but he studies
lizards he's that kind that's what he
wants you to believe
in this area you have to be very clear i
know
oh boy uh we're an hour okay i'm not
totally sure where we were
i'm gonna pick two more that i see here
and then we will
stop for the day could some sort of meta
religion
combat the current movement a reverse
engineered critical race theory wokeness
centered around the universal soul
providing a template
that even a hardened atheist could
support what would that look like
yeah in some sense you have to have
something that nourishes
that part of the human psyche i keep
saying it can't be a religion but you
know you formulated it as a meta
religion and i agree it has to do
something and in fact what we see
in this movement is a malformed
version of this it's you know it's
not metaphorical it's phony baloney
right
and that phony baloney stuff is
misleading people because it
promises them something and uh
an honorable version that promised them
something
attainable based on logic and things
would be much more effective yeah
okay one more question but there's two
comments here that i'm going to read
because they're nice
just wanted to say i love you too thank
you thanks
and please remind people that like your
videos and streams more often the
message of reason deserves to be boosted
all right yeah neither of us likes doing
it but no i hate it yeah but we hit
200 000 subscribers today that's great
that's wonderful
that's excellent okay final question
candy that's abram x kendi argues that
all cultures quote are equal in all
their divergences
saul thomas sowell or sewell says soul i
never get it right
says quote cultures exist to serve
people
and thereby a hierarchy is created what
are your thoughts
these are the wow such two relevant
quotes to put right by
side by side that's good yeah so candy
are
all cultures are equal in all their
divergences so will cultures exist to
serve people and therefore
there is a hierarchy yeah i'm not a
candy fan but
uh he's not really wrong
in the sense that culture is
adaptive in the same way that genes are
adaptive
it is a match for a set of problems
so all cultures that exist are
valid um but they're not all
equally adaptive under all circumstances
right in fact
they are they will be adapted to the
opposite maximally adapted for a
particular place sometime in which they
evolved
but you know can you say is uh you know
are ants better than elephants
right right that's not a legit question
people are adults go
right yeah you can't do it so the point
is all cultures are valid relative to
the problems they evolve to solve
to the extent that one wants to say is
there a hierarchy
well there actually is extinct cultures
are
inferior to the ones that replaced them
so and that's not to say that sometimes
it wasn't chance
right some sometimes things will have
licked that blinked out of existence
uh due to bad luck but not always right
but in general a sequential
uh pattern is going to result in
improvement relative to the problems
that are consistent in the environment
so that exists
too but soul is right
that um cultures exist to serve
people that these are means to an end
which is something that cultural
anthropologists bought
oh so badly amazingly right they don't
understand that these are means to an
end and the most frightening thing of
all
well this is i mean this we don't need a
cultural anthropology lesson here but
this i point at clifford geertz
uh most most strongly here and say you
know he started this madness
that culture is basically entirely
random you could basically pick yeah
it's arbitrary you could say this
culture
these people oh you could just swap them
and it would just be just as likely to
have evolved
no that is exactly not what culture is
right so
the punch line here is that culture
evolves
to serve the genetic interests of the
individuals that hold that culture
and that has frightening implications
they are
highly relevant to the puzzle that we
find ourselves trapped in
and we really have to get this right as
as bitter a pill as that is
all the hopeful stuff lies beyond our
understanding of it once we
get that through our heads then we can
figure out how to democratize
culture so that we all have access to
the highest quality tools
and we stop going after each other
because to the extent that it serves
our genetic interests our genes do not
want things for us
that match the values that we all
actually hold
right so their teams may want you to
engage in genocide but
um don't do it get done yeah
all right i think we're there we're
there so on that note like subscribe
comment circulate all that stuff all of
it
and uh i love it and yeah uh
if you are interested in one of these uh
conversations
that brett has with his uh higher tier
patrons they'll be happening saturday
and sunday so you need to sign up before
then yeah bring your a game though yeah
yeah yeah b
games not accepted nope uh
all right be well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you